and as we prepare for the grand opening  of resorts world it's easy to see our  city has come back to life  loosened restrictions packed casinos  have led to what analysts are calling a  real economic recovery  a new study by top agency ranking nevada  is the seventh fastest state in the  nation  for economic recovery from the cobid  pandemic  it's amazing to see how people are like  rebounding from this people have the  the the resources now to actually  do something fun like go to las vegas  professor miller says even though the  signs were seen are really positive  economists are keeping an eye on the  delta variant which he says  could have the potential to cause some  issues in the future